[Musik]
viel spaß die hin und weg wünscht de
erhält können
[Musik]
das wollen wir auch im
prinzip
richtig
als wir unsere beziehungen an linien war
meine mutter sehr beeindruckt
ein ausländer ein schweizer
[Musik]
ja
prof
mit dem mega ehrensberger bin unterwegs
von größte markt für ganz westafrika
alles als
schnecke
[Musik]
berlin gab es so eine zum teil
nachdem
[Musik]
die afrikanische land schnecken sind
ghana delikatesse aber nur für mich
die stoff wird mafia aus wanddekoration
für das hotel
und grad normal wird zu vielen dick
vietoris belege für die gäste
sehr freundliche person kennengelernt
aber das geschäftsjahr muss wartet auf
sie oder
manchmal bin ich schon etwas strenger es
hängt vom gast ab ist er freundlich
billig ist auch wenn nicht kann ich auch
strenger sein
auf dem parkplatz drive moderieren er
macht im auto gerade deal die keynote
der bündel wechsel besitzer also gott
geldwechsel
text
bewegt sich gar schon fast wie heimische
bleibt lazio rom zu ihrer familie dort
erst mal war ich schon vor 17 jahren
noch musik studium hat er dort lernt
rolle spielen wenn eine kaputte springt
sie zum oder tandems aber meistens
einfach
guten tag
willkommen lange her
da eine trommel ja wir brauchen wieder
mal eine ziege
eine seite ziege und eine plastik ja die
lassen wir so
gehen wir zusammen ein trommelfell
kaufen
[Musik]
am anfang and media und er fernbeziehung
zwischen der schweiz und ghana führt
[Musik]
noch einen job
suchen
sollte mal eine woche lang was ist
wenn politik macht genau und und er
atmete sehr hoch
[Musik]
wo ist seine zum leiter händler
günstiger der in rickenbach
da ich bin jetzt roma weg wohne dort
hoben leere da unten warm kopfes dann
selbst sehen und die bühne ist
eigentlich wie wenig sie wo man hin
erprobt haben mit dem garn ballett
24 trommlern us bürger stehen sie aber
gleich stabil
siehst du das loch
wir prüfen ob das ziegenleder ein loch
hat
das hier hat kein loch
das sie es gut
ja das denke ich auch
dvd sind fast fertig mit boston zum
znacht gibt es im hotel geräucherter
fisch auswahl ist riesig probieren
wünscht
[Musik]
die trägerinnen sie meistens juni frauen
organen des gibt es nur wenige strunk
mit hauptstadt
accra boom it-wirtschaft ganzes land mit
ganz viel rohstoff gold ist das
wichtigste exportgut strom im land
früher goldküste
kolonialmächten ghana früher anfangen
ausbildet es ist die grösste
handelsplatz für sparfüchse die
befestigte fords oder küste erinnere da
das dunkle kapitel
in 10 75 statt sich ghana vom british
empire befreit und als erstes
schwarzafrikanisches land sind die
unabhängigkeit ausgerufen mit gilt als
politisch stabil aber ein viertel von
der bevölkerung ist
[Musik]
dies war
meine mutter hat mir den rat gegeben
wenn du einen menschen besser
kennenlernen willst ist mit ihm
wenn du ihn noch besser kennenlernen
willst mach mit ihm eine reise
[Musik]
sharon und der matthias mann soll sind
viel gereist bevor ältere worden sind
jetzt ist es am stück bach tag
[Musik]
und das gerade im großen stil im moment
stehe ich vor bekannten und freunde für
mit ihnen
[Musik]
ein harter tag
viel zu viel
das zu viel gibt's nicht höchstens zu
wenig zeit und so wenig mehr
die chinesen lieben schweizer brot vor
allem schauen special
unter der woche schaffte matthias als
qualitätsmanager in einer schweizer
firma
sie ist organisationstalent druckt audi
hat uhr
wird mit dem resultat
dass es vollkommen brot mit einer dünnen
und noch einen wert immer so
weitermachen noch im plan und den zimmer
planmäßige person drei halbjahre fertig
mit bach
okay okay so
nein hier ist es zu dick und dazu dienen
so ist das backblech
sagte sagte
sagte
mir ist die form sehr wichtig und die
qualität die wir unseren kunden und
freunden bieten
so schlecht bin ich nun auch wieder
nicht dir ist das halt wichtige
manchmal gibt auch streit aber wir
gehören zu den menschen die sich schnell
wieder vertragen
es ist noch nicht fertig oder
ist es nicht doch es ist nicht okay so
läuft ich sage es ist ok er sagt es ist
nicht okay
es ist auch ein beziehungstest
wir arbeiten als team zusammen wir gehen
nicht einfach zusammen shoppen oder so
das hier ist etwas anderes
die geburt vom pläne johnson ich bald
zieht nur aber wurde in sharon ihre
mutter hörte team zieht mit die junge
familie unter einem dach
[Musik]
sie ist weltmeisterin
vor der usa auf langenthal im kanton
bern
ist neu die high unterbricht howard war
zwei tage ist die schweiz zurück für ihn
das nicht so flach dass
montana ist seine heimat für sie und
ihren mann sheikh sie aber es hier noch
ihre beiden töchter wo sie der schweiz
trug lohan
nach dass das ca
und das sei
gut
so
[Musik]
der
us-amerikanische gedanken sind häufig
bei ihm
krebs operation kann
[Musik]
nun sind die beiden so lang
wie geht du siehst wunderbar aus ich bin
so glücklich das wird großartig hier es
ist so schön du willst es lieben wie
geht es dir du fehlst mir die letzten
zwei nächte waren schrecklich aber es
geht mir schon viel viel besser
bald kommen die fäden raus morgen
morgen um halb zwei
wie gehts buch er vermisse dich so sehr
du fehlst mir so fiel es mir noch mehr
macht das schlafzimmer bereits ich komme
bald
ich liebe dich baby
bis bald
und plötzlich ja durch stoppen wieder
raus plötzlichen das sagen
hallo
baby ist die jüngere tochter bringt
[Musik]
gefahrt
[Gelächter]
brigitta zum gate usa gezogen ist hat
sie ihre beiden töchtern aus erster ehe
die schweiz zurück lag der wert bei
ihrem vater bleibt das ist für alle ganz
einfach
jetzt haben möchtest
[Musik]
es geht nur noch treffer trennt sich nun
von früher
[Musik]
im kulturzentrum
fi alliance boots tour
sie denkt dass ihr mal hotelmanager wird
wo sie mit 15 kanzlei von undercover
schweiz in einem haus schlecht die
erfahrung gemacht wie sie im user
leasing und ruhig
ich bin nie sie schließlich führt mafia
wie eine mutter und vorstädte tag
darf erzählt dass sie die ja viel
verdient wie zum beispiel ihre
unabhängigkeit
ich habe meinen kindern beigebracht dass
sie arbeiten sollen
wenn du einen job hast dann brauchst du
niemanden mehr du kannst alles selber
machen
wie stolz auf mich
ja ich bin stolz
[Gelächter]
aber magath ließ sie hilft zum beispiel
wenn sie auto streikt
das wasser
wenn du weiter fährst kriegst du
probleme
wir sollten jemanden holen der sich
damit auskennt
ich habe schon herumtelefoniert
wenn du weiter fest der motor kaputt
[Musik]
ich war mit bäder in einem klub zu klub
ja und mein mann schimpfte wieso gehst
du in den club und nicht zur kirche ich
sagte nein ich gegen tanzen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
wir waren doch die meisten jugendlichen
auf der welt verbringen die beiden
söhnen und levin ihre freizeit gern
mitnehmen
da füllt sich langsam mit gest
er soll das kulturzentrum realisieren
das hätte der bäderlandschaft bauleitung
die frau hanks
na
und
so gleitet und sie weiß wie sie tickt
muss ago
mit deiner vorhanden
also da wirst du dir selber nicht
zutraue
umspanne fahrzeug für die sie versammelt
sich mehr und mehr menschen und jeder
weiß bescheid
alle kennen und
nachteile
katia helfen sie mir leid und das ist
wichtig da muss ich muss dann verliert
keine und da war man natürlich irgendwie
wichtige orte
zu träumen das thalia als in der schweiz
vitamin b und zählt damit er bekam den
job oder so ob das wirklich
die richtige polizei
[Musik]
2010 war backen noch nicht so verbreitet
wie heute
ich dachte das ist echt cool
man kann cookies brot und sogar kuchen
backen backen ist also nicht nur sein
hobby sondern auch meine
das hatten wir beide in unserem rucksack
unabhängig voneinander brachten wir
diese leidenschaft für das backen schon
mit
[Musik]
die der chinesische staat gucci ist es
nachmittag worten
ich bin fertig mit dem zopf
dann fängst du mit den cranberries und
den rosinen an ich beginne nun mit dem
teig
gut perfekt
ihres bach projekt wird immer größer rom
1 garage
semiprofessionelle bäckerei und
es gibt einen kleinen zustupf aber er
macht damit aufgrund von geld macht es
auch spaß macht aber ich kenne sowohl
die megametropole
komisches im mega zum mitmachen
thomas cook bietet da gefreut zu machen
[Musik]
hallo schnell kommen rein
zeigt nicht doch kurz
brot backe ich auch in sozialer event
gibt das ist ein geschenk ein
selbstgemachter kuchen
heute ist unser hochzeitstag
so könnt ihr alle ein wenig mit feiern
sogar ihrem hochzeitstag wird bei
matthias und scherrenbacher stock 4
[Musik]
vorsicht ist noch drin
noch nie stand peter matthias über acht
brotbacken
claudia wir stoßen an unsere grenzen
vor allem ich
arbeite die ganze woche und den
wochenende backe ich einen ganzen tag
den sonntag verbringe ich mit jonas in
unserem baby
backen ist ein hobby wir lieben es aber
wenn es keinen spaß mehr macht hören wir
auch
der kontakt mit freunden muss brodkorb
hole entschädigt sie für ihre strenge
b12 an jan ist ein schweizer mit
chinesischen wurzeln
und das macht und waren immer ein büro
oder
moment mag google hauptvereins von
google oder
wirtschaftsbrücke zu messen
das
thema
[Musik]
lautet sind
das werden
wir
sehen
[Musik]
für ihren traum vom kulturzentrums kann
entweder und mafia mitgliedes lebe in
der schweiz hinter sich laut gunnar
ganze großfamilie und den alltag ohne zu
erheben und wo sichern hier langweilig
wird
[Musik]
werdet ihr bliebe in ghana oder könnte
irgendwann wieder zurück
ich bin so glücklich hier meine familie
ist auch hier ich werde sowieso wieder
in der schweiz ferien machen aber ob ich
wieder dorthin
haben
wir meist nicht zurück musste man turbo
und draußen das motor steht und das ist
durch
was denkst du werden
unternehmen werden so groß
aber jetzt ist immer noch ja ich weiß es
noch nicht aber mit lebensweise hinweise
was ist wenn die person den raum der
kunst lockern
ja ich denke wir
es war nicht genannt
[Musik]
viele der
fia unter peter als mit xp
danken schritt in die andere welt kennt
sie auch sich selber noch mal neu
erfinden
[Musik]
es war dieser moment als sich ihr
piercing sei sie sagt irgendetwas bla
bla bla bla und ich dachte nur darüber
nach was es wohl für ein gefühl wäre sie
zu küssen
liebe kennt keine grenze
auch starte und die kursgebühren über
welche hypo ist mein andere land
verliebt migrations bestimmte bürokratie
der ganze papier trägt das für viele
binational ich war echte bewährungsprobe
andrea unter pedro hätten eher versteckt
monatelang durchgemacht
laut zechner
schuldig der
reise ist andrea götz ihre große liebe
schafft vor zweieinhalb jahren hat sie
ein großer trip durch südamerika welle
machen kolumbien hat sie der übersetzer
beethoven sportler sind essbar worte der
petro ist sie drei männer die schweiz
besuchen kurzarbeit ist andrea widerruf
kolumbien flog mit ganz speziellen im
gepäck
ja oder ja schon gesagt wir das gleiche
hat eine kleine süßigkeit sie für ihn
kochen will ich heuer nicht so viel
gepäck
man ist einfach so ein zwischending
macht mir wirklich
schön
ja das ist der
traum hochzeit am strand von columbia
ich platzt dokumente vollständig
erschienen vor venezuela seit worden der
heimat von pedro das land wo bekanntlich
für sie die komplizierte bürokratie
andreas eyd kein staat auf der welt gibt
sony europe chance zum 2 0 ab
[Musik]
der nägeli moosmayer hätten pedro offs
im schnitt besonders gefallen dort mit
andrea warum sie der pandemie ihre liebe
verdankt
du bist allein auf südamerika reise
auf der suche nach einem verein auf der
suche nach
freiheit vielleicht oder für ihn auch
nach der arbeit nicht im arbeitsalltag
und einfach
entscheiden
und das ist
ganz speziell
studiert doch eine vorstellen dass
daneben sitzt irgendwo auf dem level wie
hier mir im laden
das
unternehmen brauche und dann hatte
ich hatte richtig funktioniert
und dann habe ich zum glück
dann ist er der einzig sie in sonder
motto wo ich nur kann dann hat er kein
job
hilft das wasser schleppen durch die
unterstützung
der bmw relativ schön ich meine er mit
dem turiner zimmer leonie de erklärt
natürlich an erzählkunst und wohnwägen
sie maria und dem hc ralf ackermann
blieb und hat nur kurzzeitig
gewirkt
ich glaube so eine richtige moment aber
nicht
unbedingt ohne ihn eigentlich
hoffnung dass sie bald renz erleben
kennt andrea und pedro de la paz
hochsitz wiesenfeld immer
[Musik]
ganz gleich mit ihm einig sie denn sie
machen was sie
sich durch ob ist als dass ich habe aber
meistens seien so diskussion ist sage
ich luke wenn du glücklich beispiel
google co nein wir suchen nach einem
kompromiss
das ehemalige fischerdorf an der küste
von pacific mit einfach das schönste
strand von ecuador über 70 menschen
ein depot ist der schweizer tom fried er
und seine lebensgefährtin an
das hotel
[Musik]
die
musik
[Musik]
wie geht's sehr gut jetzt sind die
dran wie immer
die kleine sie ins training sie macht
noch hausaufgaben für die schule sie
muss dann zum unterricht
[Musik]
carlitos zanni und tochter von der
anstieg
vom hotel direkt am meer hätte tom schon
träumt wollen uns europa ausbauen
kriegsschiff verteilt und
lateinamerikanische frauen schon im rat
an schäfer übers internet kennengelernt
und auch viele hindernis als schwerste
ihre gefunkt er war der erste schweizer
den ich kennengelernt habe
er ist so fürsorglich und aufmerksam
meine freundinnen sagten zeigt ihn her
wir wollen auch so einen bring
schokolade mit und finde uns auch einen
single mit geld hat er keinen bruder
oder cousin bringen sie hier stellen sie
uns vor
wie ecuadorianer sind ganz anders sie
haben halt auf zwei bis drei frauen wenn
nicht mehr
weißt du noch der typ der innerhalb
einer woche mit zwei verschiedenen
frauen zu uns kam
die europäer sind da ganz anders
wenn sie nichts mehr von dir wollen
machen sie schluss
ich habe thomas schon oft gesagt wenn du
mich nicht mehr willst dann sagt mir ich
weiß aber ich liebe dich so sehr
[Musik]
2009 hätte turm zum ersten mal kontakt
mit der angie oft nur
ganze sechs jahre braucht bis sie als
bar und patchwork familie sei nach hause
[Musik]
endlich ist er da der tag wird bringt
sie zwei monaten gegen vier brit ihrem
arzt usa für immer
so lang sind die beiden nun ihr drängt
sie
etwa hat seine krebsoperation kann das
machte brighi zurück was mir jetzt
einfacher warteschlange
hoffe dass
er so schnell wie möglich zum arzt
wir werden
sicher mindestens
als heimat für 20 25 jahren
positiv
wo kommst du denn her
[Musik]
glücklich ja ich bin glücklich ich war
so aufgeregt warum einfach so aufgeregt
wegen einlegen ich bin so erleichtert
dass alles gut gegangen ist
gut her zu sein
[Musik]
es geht mir prima endlich sind wir
zusammen wer drei musketiere
[Musik]
komplett
ist da nicht groß geworden aber so klein
als sie ging ja er ist in die höhe
geschossen ich kann es kaum glauben
in der nächsten folge von hin und weg
china ist selber gemacht die schweizer
brot heiß begehrt aber cheron untermarkt
die aus bringt der stress
wir sind ein team ein team
wenn jetzt das sagt
oder beeil dich
[Musik]
lieber mit der schweiz trotz ihrer
krankheit glaubt er fest dass sie nie
zieht monika graf ich
mache mir keine sorgen der schöpfer hat
uns hier vereint ich soll noch nicht
sterben
und garnett romantische ski wurde tom
sie vor elf jahren
für mich eigentlich war
zusammengebrochen
erwarten
die androhung ist platz für 20 jahre
[Musik]
die kalorien
den und präsentiert wurde von dr